joe is serving 22 years inside the
federal medical center in fort worth
texas
for wildlife violations and a plot to
kill
carol baskin and now in his first prison
interview joe says
he's counting on carol to get him out
carolyn howard basking said that they
would vow to help me
get a pardon and probably support the
big fat safety act it is time for carol
howard to put up or shut the hell up
because
i'm accepting their offer
yeah not so fast because there is still
no love lost here
joe exotic broke his silence for the
first time after howard baskin made this
ultimatum to the mirror quote
if joe were to come out and say i would
like to support passage of the big cat
public
safety act it might position him in a
positive way for a pardon and frankly i
might be willing to go and urge at least
a reduction in his sentence
if they can't think the way it's written
is not gonna help
anybody except peter and carol baskin
so other than that they need to stay the
hell out of the news with all their crap
just to get their name in the paper
because i just called their bluff et
reached out to carol who said they stand
by their offer with one major caveat
quote i wouldn't seek a reduced sentence
for joe based upon him
just saying he'd help he'd have to
actually work with authorities to bring
all of his buddies to justice and work
with legislators to end
cub listen if handling
live through this because my health is
deteriorating by the day
we're going to turn this into something
good my stand for prison and justice
reform
joe has been behind bars for two and a
half years so far and claims the prison
system is not adequately addressing
medical issues
i weighed again last week and i lost
another 10 pounds
and i have to get blood infusions as
opposed to every four weeks
that i've only been getting about every
three months i have
hemogamoglobin anemia they used to take
me downtown to
the cancer center for treatment but we
stopped doing that
i refused treatment for tuberculosis
last week my mouth is full of ulcers i
cannot eat
i look bad despite all that joe says his
husband of three years dylan passage
is sticking by his side despite putting
out a statement three weeks ago they
were seeking a divorce the guy has been
through hell
and he has stood by my side the entire
time
we were talking about a divorce a few
weeks ago
so he could move on and we we talked
about it some more and then we decided
to speak mary
he just told me over and over okay if i
make it out of here alive
i still have a home to come to i am
dylan
i'm done by the way this tiger king saga
is being turned into a limited series by
nbc now snl star kate mckinnon will play
carol baskin
and we just learned john cameron
mitchell who won a tony for hedwig and
the angry inch
will play joe exotic and don't forget
cbs
also has a tiger king project in the
works for amazon
that will star nicholas cage is so
exotic i love it